the first time I cried underwater was in
2008 the island of Curacao
way down in the Southern Caribbean it's
beautiful there
I was studying these corals for my PhD
and after days and days of diving on the
same reef I had gotten to know them as
individuals I had made friends with
coral colonies totally a normal thing to
do then
hurricane Omar smashed them apart and
ripped off their skin leaving little
bits of wounded tissue that would have a
hard time healing and big patches of
dead skeleton that would get overgrown
by algae when I saw this damage for the
first time stretching all the way down
the reef I sunk onto the sand in my
scuba gear and I cried if a coral could
died that fast how could a reef ever
survive and why was I making it my job
to try to fight for them I never heard
another scientist feel that kind of
story until last year a scientist in
Guam wrote I cried right into my mask
seeing the damage on the reef and the
scientists on Australia wrote I showed
my students the results of our coral
surveys and we wept crying about corals
of having a moment guys and that's
because reefs in the Pacific are losing
corals faster than we've ever seen
before because of climate change the
water is so hot for so long in the
summers that these animals can't
function normally they're spitting out
the colored algae that lives in their
skin and the clear bleached tissue
that's left
usually starves to death and then rots
away and then the skeletons are
overgrown by algae this was happening
over an unbelievable scale the northern
Great Barrier Reef lost two-thirds of
its corals last year over a distance of
hundreds of miles then bleached again
this year and the bleaching stretched
further south reefs in the Pacific are
in a nosedive right now and no one knows
how bad it's going to get except over in
the Caribbean where I work
we've already been through the nosedive
reefs there have suffered through
centuries of intense human abuse we kind
of already know how the story goes
and we might be able to help predict
what happens next
let's consult a graph since the
invention of scuba scientists have
measured the amount of coral on the sea
floor and how it's changed through time
and after centuries of ratcheting human
pressure Caribbean reefs met one of
three fates some reef lost their corals
very quickly some reefs lost their
corals more slowly but kind of ended up
in the same place okay so far this is
not going very well but some reefs in
the Caribbean the ones best protected
and the ones a little further from
humans they managed to hold on for their
girls give us a challenge and we almost
never saw a reef hit zero the second
time I cried underwater was on the North
Shore of Curacao 2011 it was the calmest
day of the year but it's always pretty
sketchy diving there my boyfriend and I
swam against the waves
I watched my compass that we could find
our way back out and he watched for
sharks and after 20 minutes of swimming
that felt like an hour we finally
dropped down to the reef and I was so
shocked and I was so happy that my eyes
filled with tears
there were corals a thousand years old
lined up one after another they had
survived the entire history of European
colonialism in the Caribbean and for
centuries before that I never knew what
a coral could do when it was given a
chance to thrive the truth is that even
as we lose so many corals even as we go
through this massive coral die off some
reefs will survive some will be ragged
on the edge some will be beautiful and
by protecting shorelines and giving us
food to eat and supporting tourism they
will still be worth billions and
billions of dollars a year the best time
to protect a reef was fifty years ago
but the second
time is right now and even as we go
through bleaching events more frequent
and in more places some corals will be
able to recover
we had a bleaching event in 2010 in the
Caribbean that took off big patches of
skin on bolder corals like these this
coral lost half of its skin but if you
look at the side of this coral a few
years later this coral is actually
healthy again it's doing what a healthy
coral does making copies of its polyps
it's fighting back the algae and it's
reclaiming its territory if a few polyps
survive a coral can regrow it just needs
time and protection in a reasonable
temperature some girls can regrow in ten
years
others take a lot longer but the more
stresses we take off them locally things
like overfishing sewage pollution
fertilizer pollution dredging coastal
construction the better they can hang on
as we stabilize the climate and the
faster they can regrow and as we go
through the long tough and necessary
process of stabilizing the climate of
planet Earth some new corals will still
be born this is what I study in my
research we try to understand how corals
make babies and how those babies find
their way to the reef and we invent new
methods to help them survive those early
fragile life stages one of my favorite
coral babies of all time showed up right
after Hurricane Omar it's the same
species I was studying before the storm
but you almost never see babies of the
species it's really rare and this is
actually an endangered species in this
photo this little baby coral is little
circle of polyps is a few years old like
its cousins that bleach is fighting back
the algae and like its cousins on the
north shore
it's aiming to live for a thousand years
what's happening in the world and in the
ocean has changed our time horizon we
can be incredibly pessimistic on the
short term and more on what we lost and
what we really took for granted but we
can still be optimistic on the long term
and we can still be ambitious about what
we fight for and what we expect from
our governments from our planets corals
have been living on planet earth for
hundreds of millions of years they
survived the extinction of the dinosaurs
they're their badasses an individual
coral can go through tremendous trauma
and fully recover if it's given a chance
and it's given protection corals have
always been playing the long game
and now so are we thanks very much
[Applause]